well let's look at some images released
by the Ministry of Defense this morning
that showed preparations last night for
those tornado gr4s before they took off
on their mission here you see a storm
shadow missile being loaded underneath
the aircraft as the ground teams in RAF
Akrotiri readied them for that mission
near Syrian airspace not quite into
Syrian airspace they stayed at safer
distance but they fire those storm
shadow missiles pre-programmed to follow
a GPS trajectory they fly low mapping
the terrain as they go and just as they
get towards their target they rise up in
altitude before then taking a dip back
down to try and be precise they can
relay information back to the cockpit of
the aircraft at real-time so that will
provide a lot of the aftermath
intelligence as to whether or not this
was an effective attack that plus a
package of surveillance aircraft that
will be in the air above Syria at the
moment getting what's in his BDA battle
damage assessment to try and establish
whether or not these strikes last night
were successful let's put all that onto
a map for you so you've got some idea
for the geography and what else went on
so as we were talking about RAF Akrotiri
in Cyprus and that eastern Mediterranean
coast and that major British airbase
firing for some for tornados firing
Storm Shadow missiles what were the
targets while these were very precisely
thought through none of the wider scope
operations that hadn't been anticipated
beforehand no airfields targeted in
quite the same way that we are aware of
instead three chemical sites one near
Damascus two on the outskirts of Homs
one of those 15 miles from Homs that was
the site that was attacked by the RAF
all connected to Syria's chemical
weapons program either production
development stockpile or use of chemical
weapons are known to these sites so this
would have been a cooperative effort
from the various intelligence agencies
France Britain and the United Kingdom to
establish
precise targets and to make sure that
the response was proportionate
- what happened in Duma last weekend
let's focus in now on Damascus last
night there were reports of heavy
anti-aircraft fire in the night skies
above Damascus and a number of
explosions around the capital city one
of the reasons that they launched the
air strikes in the middle of the night
not just to give them cover under the
cloak of darkness but also to make sure
that you minimize the number of
potential civilian casualties in the
hope that at 3:00 4:00 a.m. in the
morning most people are at home in bed
and asleep there was a threat though and
that threat came from Russia it was the
big unknown how would they respond and
might that project this into a war
beyond what anybody wanted the s400 is
Russia's air defense system based on the
western coast of Syria near Latakia as
far as we know it did not open up on
either the aircraft or the missiles why
not did Russia decide that they did not
want to take this conflict down that
route and exacerbate it further still or
perhaps the coalition was successful in
using technology to jam that radar
system perhaps we'll find out later when
more information is given to us both
from Washington London and Paris